thing if a woman come to me and said
look I've been graved by this person I
would rather believe her and find out
she's a liar than then turn my back on
her and believe a grape is true that's
one there we are that's one thing about
your son what do you mean I would I
would disagree I came to you and said
that your son but this is all
situational because I could turn around
to you and say wow that ain't never
gonna happen like I don't know why
you're trying to leave someone I don't
know that that's stupid I never said you
didn't like I didn't know he's gonna
believe someone because it's worse but
you would believe they're not a great
piece you don't know that I I wouldn't
believe anybody until the facts come out
and and so you're you made the claim
that the majority of women that come
forward they're telling the truth right
oh yeah I would say okay but if that was
true then why aren't the don't the
majority of girls that press charges why
don't they why don't they go to jail
if the evidence there is there they go
to jail what the woman if she's full
Syracuse Goes to Jail no no I'm sorry
I'm saying the majority of girls that
press charges it doesn't get taken to
the to court they don't go to jail okay
and so and so I'm saying why
I think I think you're maybe missing a
point in the how much that no no no no
you can't understand the claim yeah no
no this is what I'm trying to explain
that that how much the system is set up
to not listen to women I know women
me too is like one of the biggest music
I'm trying to tell you I'm trying to
tell you stuff to back my claims but
yeah I apologize I've known a woman to
be abused by her police officer's
husband to go to call with evidence and
it's to be thrown out I've known women
to have been great who have had to drive
nearly five hours down the road to the
country to to be set down by a policeman
and tell her that they ain't interested
in it I've seen it all right so I I
understand again because I'm traumatized
I'm not worth listening to but at the
same time I can't understand no no I
can't understand that I've got all of
this to say to you and there's still a
client uh the only man I've known to be
falsely accused
great sorry sorry so I know I it's not
that it's not that we're not we don't
respect what you're saying anecdotal
evidence when it's not backed by data
no what I'm saying is backed by data
because you can look at the numbers you
can look at you can look up the number
of women that report a crime and you can
look up how many men were actually press
charges and it is not the majority so
I'm saying like you're just going based
off of word I'm going off of Base I'm
going based off of evidence but that
sometimes that doesn't it's not looking
at them you don't know as a woman what
it's like to be accused
and so as a man yeah we understand that
that type of accusation yeah could
destroy our whole life 100 yeah if if if
it is false it can destroy our whole
life
hang on no but hang on but hang on as a
man
as men hear if we get falsely accused of
that right it doesn't at this time it
doesn't even matter whether we've done
it or not oh the only thing the only
thing that matters is that people
believe it yeah yeah right in these days
and times so when we are asking for
evidence of it yeah and you say oh well
the majority of women that say it it's
happened to them which as a man I'm
thinking but it hasn't been proven and
as a man I'm gonna require some kind of
proof to show that this thing has
happened because if I get falsely
accused I know that my life's finished
everyone every man here knows if they
get falsely accused their life is
finished so wouldn't it just be more
fair
for there to be evidence to back up your
claim but the thing is I generally think
it's out there on the internet I I got
phone I haven't got the numbers on my
head I said that I'm sorry I I don't
even know what do you want me to look up
if you talk if you talk about great
statistics and and false allegations
okay okay false allegations is there a
stat that I can look at I think it was I
think it was the great crisis
um can I I can't use my phone because
can I just say you can't you can you can
use it for the symptoms
can I just say that on this show before
we spoke of a book called how to destroy
a man right there's a book on Amazon
that you can buy called how to destroy a
man
on Amazon right now and it's a handbook
for women yeah put it actually you can
Google it right now it's called how to
destroy a man it's a handbook as to how
women can leverage allegations and for
and for and accusations right against
men right and that was it was actually
published in 2018. so for publicly or
it's on Amazon
so if a book like that can be published
as to how to destroy a man who as men
think of us as men we don't know
I think there's a first of all there's a
Marketplace second of all we don't know
who's read it can I can I just can I
just say something that I would never
agree with that as much as we don't
agree I'm not going to sit here as a
woman and say yeah oh yeah that's fine
that's fine that's fine but I will say
like when you're making that when you're
saying about that and that's really
outrageous to you do you not find the
outrageous that there's categories on
websites
of girls being great there's there's
Reddit there's a website when when you
was talking
um about Netflix about oh not Netflix
sorry about that man in America who who
lost all of everything there's there's
um
a documentary on Netflix called Aubry
and Daisy about two girls in an American
High School that both got graped they
both ended up killing themselves they
both got kicked out of school because
the men that done the boys had done it
to them were were seen as the
Untouchable because their parents had
links
you keep bringing up these super sad
situations and I agree we don't like
rapists and I agree that false
allegations are terrible but I think one
outweighs the other no no the difference
this is what feminists do they're always
competing with that's the floor it's
always a competition like I'm saying I'm
saying it's not it's not a competition
I'm not saying it's a competition but
I'm saying Miss Andre is a is a
consequence of all it is no no it's not
a consequence
there's no accountability if you're
justifying your your poor Behavior no
that's why by blaming it on a very small
groups
things that come out of your mouth are
very misandristic yes
I'm saying like all men are men
it's when you're talking about men in a
general way like we should be afraid of
them it's is that what you were saying I
I think if I had a daughter I would be
bringing her up to be conscious and of
being but this is the thing again I'm
coming from a situation where I've got a
son who's no no who's not at all I would
love you to meet my boy because my boy
is is incredible he really is like I
said I've got women at a school Gates
come on I've got women at the school
Gates who are old enough to be my mum
who are married telling me my son's a
good kid I wish my boy was like yours I
like the fact that my boy plays videos
my boy I've brought him up not to enable
stuff I said to him you are who your
friends are so when all of his mates
want to go around playing knocked down
Ginger and Nick and things from the
neighbors he comes in he's going to a
very very good school he's a good kid so
the fact that you're looking at me and
thinking oh she can't raise a boy but
when In fairness I have raised a really
good there's lots of good boys out there
we don't know your son no but when
what I'm saying is I think it's really
sad to raise a kid with your view on men
I think that is that's fine
and then tell me how much why is his
father not influencing him as well I I
don't want to get into that that's my
son's personal enough I'm not gonna say
I'm not going to talk about that um it I
I think what's what's most worrying for
me is you you justify these extreme
viewpoints would you consider yourself
as being kind of um indoctrinated no I
should tell you what like I said you
have an objective Viewpoint no no no no
so I just I just think I I can't I'm I'm
more a little bit confused as to how I'm
sitting in the room with two women who
it's not that I think every woman should
think that is I just can't this is why I
said to you like I think Miss is it Miss
Andrew is how you pronounce it I think
it's a knock-on effect on misogyny and
I'll stick to that that's my
viewed women the thing is I don't think
that I thought you believed women yeah I
don't it's not but are you who are you
accusing the grape do you know it is
I'm saying when I say my experience in
the world you don't seem to think it's
reality no I do it's just different
times because it's just different you
know I'll give I'll give you an example
like when she was talking you would say
oh it's just because you're young but
instead of you know believing women like
I thought feminists do you you discount
her experience because she's young I
should tell you what but this is the
thing if I'm gonna listen to any advice
I'm gonna listen to someone older so
when I was saying about the Nature
Reserve I'm listening to women who are
74. well educated married married should
tell you what and the ones that aren't
are [ __ ] happy as Larry they've got
their they've got their friends they do
their clubs and all of this so the thing
is I'm listening to women and they
haven't got kids like the one that I'm
talking to has hasn't got kids but at
the same time I'm talking to a 74 year
old who was about when women were
allowed to be having contraception and
she told me that that when she went to
UNI you would have to take a marriage
certificate to the doctor to get
contraception which is weird actually
contraception yeah I think we should too
yeah well I think we should ban it it
has weird effects yeah oh 100 it's got
weird effects on women but then you're
gonna have a lot of unwanted pregnancies
no or you could just you know make
better sexual decisions you know or just
except there were animals and we like to
enjoy ourselves you you might be an
animal but I'm not so like no no I'm not
saying that for yourself here you are
trying to make it out though I've just
outing myself as some slack I'm saying
we're animals women have urges just as
men yeah but we're human we can control
them of course this is why I say to them
but you say about men that that if a man
behind his wife's back in my handshake
most men do control their urges one one
out of three Mana virgins are haven't
had sex in the past year if we're going
to talk about cheating I don't condone
cheating but I think it's different from
men and for women 100 no 100 it's a
different topics yeah yeah no 100 but
again it sometimes boils down to being
an animal I don't I don't I don't think
that's that's not what I I said like
I was just ban
talk
s on a daily
worm if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible